Find the perimeter
of the parallelogram.
And we have a parallelogram
right over here.
Opposite sides are parallel.
That side is parallel to
that side right over here.
This side is parallel
to that side over here.
And also in a parallelogram,
opposite sides
have the same length.
Now, we have to worry about
the perimeter here, which
essentially just says that
if we had a field the size
or the shape of
this parallelogram,
and we wanted to make a
fence around the field that
was the shape of this
parallelogram, how long would
that fence have to be?
And obviously, it
would be the sum
of the lengths of the sides.
So we wouldn't
even have to worry
about this thing
right over here.
We could ignore it for
the sake of that problem.
We don't care about
the actual height,
or this altitude
right over here.
We just care about the
lengths of its sides.
So the perimeter of
this parallelogram
is going to be 12
inches plus 8 inches
plus 12 inches plus 8 inches.
12 plus 8 is 20.
So this is all going
to add up to 40 inches.
And we're done.
I guess this is a
very small field,
because it's only 8 inches.
I guess it would be a
little plot of land,
a little parallelogram
plot of land.
Anyway, we're done.
Its perimeter is 40 inches.